So we want to work with a data set when I
say that is I'm gonna like an Excel sheet. We have rows and
columns and you want to calculate something one
that is built into our studio. It's called
empty cars and to bring it into the file you
reference it like so you don't have to actually download anywhere.
So you when you do when you do when you run this line of
code, you can do this with me you are going to bring in
this sample data set into your file.
now if you want to get a sample of what is
contained in this data structure in this
File there's a function called Head.
Which will show you the first?
you know couple of
Rows. So for example, this data set has to
do with cards and their specifications. So for
example,
like if you want to see the entire data set.
You can click on it and this is the whole.
Data collection for this for this for this for this
car. So we have
the leftmost column of course are some car
models.
Okay, and then they're corresponding specifications.
Number of cylinders they have their horsepower their
weight.
And you can use this for example to determine their standard deviation
their variance the four moments. So for
example
If you want to read a particular column.
in this
data, you would say maybe empty cars then you would
put in the dollar sign.
And then when you put in the dollar sign, you can
then choose that particular.
A column column of data. So for example MPG
Okay, and this will tell you these are all of the values.
Contained that column.
Now, for example, we can also do you do something like summary?
You can either do summary for the whole data set.
or a summary for
a particular column
Okay, of course, you have to make sure to select that line or put your
curse at that line run the code.
And then you would get some information some brief. Now. You can
actually expand on the summary, but this is some.
This is an some glimpse into your data. So for
the mpg column.
Min means the smallest value
is 10
The biggest of them all is 33.9.
the first quartile
the number corresponding to the first quartile
is 15.43.
The median is 19.20 and so on.